[Musique]
Je suis allé à l'entraînement ces cinq
mois avant le physique des
arts martiaux, puis l'arme fonctionne
tout le temps que j'ai mis, je suis juste
meilleur dans ce domaine, les mâchoires entraînent son cul
quand nous l'entraînons, nous allons  aller pendant des heures et des
heures et des heures et il ne s'arrêtera tout simplement pas
c'est incroyable c'était vraiment l'un des
entraînements les plus difficiles que j'ai fait parce
qu'il y a beaucoup plus d'action dans Parabellum
qu'il n'y en a dans les deux autres films qu'il
s'entraîne pendant des mois il fait  sa propre action,
il est la personne la plus engagée avec qui
j'ai jamais travaillé, il fait
quatre-vingt-dix-huit pour cent de tout ce que vous
voyez à l'écran, certaines personnes disent
qu'elles veulent suivre l'entraînement de John Wick, puis ça
commence et puis ils sont comme oh ça  est
John Wick et quand Holly a dit qu'elle
voulait faire ça, Chad a dit voilà et comment
ils ont dit merci monsieur puis-je s'il vous plaît en
avoir plus je serai les six sept mois les plus difficiles
que je pense avoir vécus dans
ma vie professionnelle je  J'ai continué parce
que je n'abandonnerais pas la meilleure façon de faire semblant d'
être  le bien c'est juste d'être bon et ça
prend de la sueur du sang et des larmes c'est un niveau
d'engagement qui n'est pas normal si on
peut dire que je l'ai fait j'ai dû
apprendre à combattre le piano à une jambe et j'ai
dû apprendre à me battre avec lui  à
proximité, ils forment vraiment une équipe,
c'est tout simplement dur comme de la merde, mais c'est aussi
très amusant et j'ai une excellente équipe de personnes
qui m'apprennent à vous former